julius randle set a career high with 46
against the sacramento king several
games ago
misfires badly on his first field goal
attempt duran's off blast got it
with a chance for a three-point play
nice job by andre drummond who leads the
league in rebound percentage recognizing
all right i might have a tough angle but
i'm going to force the official into
making a call and as soon as soon as he
feels that contact on his waist 27th in
the nba in pace but they have been
playing a little bit faster of late
kevin durant always plays at his own
pace knocks down another jumper
says no sir that is a nice play
kevin durant running drills out there
shooting drills on the knicks knocks
down the baseline jumper who happens to
be coaching the opponent steve nash
became the godfather
and his dad robert asked him
as durant knocks down another three
robinson great effort to keep it alive
and he turns it over durant got a two on
one with brown bruce brown floating
[Applause]
it's not just his shot making he's
communicated at a high level on the
defensive end anticipates and then watch
the field the guy's averaging 5.8
assists per game he's not just a
brilliant scorer folks
he does so many things brooklyn sinking
into the paint relocating and making
sure he's available
hits brown on the baseline out one more
to duran
boy you can't find anymore
at the defensive end guardian kevin
durant
durant the second most prolific
mid-range score in the nba
one of those moments where hey i'm not
coming out you going out
durant
inside great find to johnson for the
layup what do i say about him his
playmaker and the play-making ability so
julius randle absorbing the assignment
he's just surveying and at his size you
can do that so if there's not enough
ball pressure right your hands are down
if you're julius so he's serving he's
seven feet julius if your hands aren't
high and you're not at least impeded
a little horn set here by brooklyn
here's kevin durant
midi pure
putter
kevin durant with 18. whether it's on
the road or with multiple bodies look at
the ball
pulls it down below his knees
just because you have corporate
knowledge of somebody doesn't mean it
helps you stop the guy
just drumming catching inside over
robinson for the bucket well i didn't
have a great angle excellent footwork by
andre drummond throws off your summer
routine but both guys have an extremely
high level
our charging boston celtics the number
one defensive team in the nba and i'm
not sure there's a defense for that guy
kevin durant
big man out of texas
here's another guy out of texas durant
with the float game got it and won by
his ability to
keep his eye on the rim
but gets the corner turned and see what
i mean
he gave it energy on that possession
here's durant
in the mid-range rising up over randall
and knocks it home
duran isolated on the wing again against
randall
on the drive-by drummond on the dump off
counted
and we got a whistle and a foul
underneath
that's a tough cover i mean julius is on
an island they lift that entire side of
the floor
and once rotation comes you know
you're
sometimes it's not always about the
money
i'll just leave it at that i'll take the
talent
sometimes it's not the money
it's a robinson right there he's got
four blocks
durant
great feathery touch gets it to fall and
that's against a double right nice job
to get a hand on it
duram straight line drive
and says it with his chest
straight line driving
lack of communication julia is standing
there looking at his teammates he was on
the strong side look at him like don't
stand there you got to be the emergency
stop he's standing there looking at his
teammates
tied at 75
[Applause]
quick pull by kd
and it's strength
well i just remember he sat for a long
time and even steve kirk
seeker steve nash touched on that
pregame
brown to the basket got it
strong finish he's got the flaps down
much much needed bucket coming out of
that timeout by the knicks
five-point ball game brown in traffic
clover randall this guy is now six for
eight
that's a shot that worked for him so
well a season ago
from the elbow durant hits brown inside
over randall again boy bruce brown
fournier on durant gotta like this
matchup if you're brooklyn
raises up over and knocks it home it's
nothing but net did he just pinch his
fingers as if to say
like
don't he didn't put his hand down
he's like this this too little you're
tiny this is close
this close evan a free from either side
i love that it was catch don't think
about it i've got an open shot let it go
durant
beats the double team and finds the
right guy clackson and one
eric with that bucket he has been
their best clutch time shooter this year
speaking of clutch durant with another
bucket he's got 42. it's prototypical if
you had a point guard like derrick rose
value the possession let's get a good
shot
up top for durant
boy james johnson with a good look
inside who's the shot maker if they
blitz him they double team them here at
the elbow
looking at a bunch of hands
durant sometimes it doesn't matter
[Applause]
says my guy is at it
retrieves it from drag
boy they're all up on kevin durant but
they gave him a little daylight
deadly
durant dynamite if kevin gives it up
early there's going to be time in the
shot clock to get it back so he gives it
up twice you can't fall asleep or lose
attachment alec burke's lost vision that
means rj had to find him again
so almost a turnover but how about this
i mean he's been
trapped they're being physical with them
but the concentration even he's
impressed by that shot